North Korea has announced it's going to
expel American Soldier Travis King
saying he's confessed to illegally
intruding into the country the 23 year
old private ran across the border from
South Korea on July the 18th while on a
guided tour Florence Louise joining us
now live from Seoul at the time this was
a controversy but also a huge
embarrassment for the U.S military what
do we know about the future holding for
Travis King
well there's not a lot of detail
released in the North Korean State media
apart from to say that authorities have
finished their questioning of King and
according to North Korean State media
king during an investigation had
confessed that he had willingly crossed
into North Korea because he was
disillusioned by unequal treatment in
U.S society and he had experienced
racism in the U.S army now at the time
um it was thought that this was a
propaganda coup for North Korea because
not only was King a U.S citizen but he
was also a U.S soldier and had willingly
crossed over into North Korea now of
course King's comments could not be
independently verified and we've also
asked the UN command in South Korea
which oversees the Armistice on the
Korean Peninsula and they've said they
have no comment with regards to the
report by North Korean State media now
we know back in August that the Pentagon
said that they their priority is to
bring King home and that they're working
through all available channels to
achieve that outcome but we have no
other detail on why North Korea is
choosing to spell King now and they've
held him for a relatively short time
only 71 days we also don't know when
he's going to be expelled or how but
previous U.S civilians have been put on
a flight via Beijing but because King is
a soldier he could be handed over to the
U.S military
um at the truce Village of palmon jump
at the demilitarized zone of the Border
separating North and South Korea
Florence thank you very much indeed
that's Florence Louis bringing us up to
date from Seoul